bonsoir à tous soyez les bienvenus dans
votre journal de l'afrique à la une de
l'actualité de ce soir le sommet de la
cedeao accra au ghana le burkina faso
échappent aux sanctions à condition de
libérer sans délai le président kaboré
est de proposer un calendrier électoral
le plus rapidement possible
madagascar se préparent au passage du
cyclone bâtira et la population est
appelé à la plus grande vigilance des
vents violents risque de balayer la côte
est de la grande île lkl borgia est sur
place pour france 24
rémy est d'amener est notre invité
l'invité du journal de l'afrique ce soir
ils étaient 3 montante du rnb affront
côte d'ivoire nous présentera son
dernier titre c'est assure à la fin de
cette édition
l'egypte qui décroche sa place en finale
pour la coupe d'afrique des nations les
pharaons ont défié le cameroun le
cameroun qui s'est donc incliné bonsoir
à vous marcela a beaucoup vous êtes dans
une fan zone à yaoundé on imagine la
tristesse tout simplement ce soir des
supporters de l'équipe nationale
oui nous sommes exactement dans la
fanzone de yannick noah l'ancien
tennisman et vous pouvez le constater
c'est le désert la plupart des personnes
qui étaient rassemblés ici depuis la fin
de la premier league sont partis après
cette séance de tirs au but insoutenable
séance de tirs au but qui a vu l'angle
les égyptiens éliminer les cabinets
pourtant l'espoir était permis après une
première mi temps où on a vu les camonin
entreprenant qui ont raté de nombreuses
occasions la deuxième mi temps elle a
été un peu plus équilibré et après le
temps réglementaire les 90 minutes
dogues les deux équipes étaient à 0 but
partout il a fallu passer par les
prolongations 30 minutes de plus et les
deux équipes n'ont toujours pas pu se
séparer de cette séance fatidique des
tirs au but qui a vu donc les égyptiens
éliminer les camerounais en demi finale
c'est une sorte de remake de la coupe
d'afrique des nations 2009 112 ici au
cameroun 50 ans après l'expérience se
répète au cameroun à cette époque-là
avait déjà été éliminé en demi-finale
lors de sa coupe d'afrique des nations
éliminées par le congo brazzaville c'est
donc une énorme déception ici au
cameroun après cette élimination des
lions indomptables qui ne joueront pas
la finale de leur coupe d'afrique des
nations merci beaucoup marcel mars l
amoco en direct depuis yaoundé du sursis
pour le lieutenant-colonel damiba pas de
sanction immédiate pour le burkina faso
mais l'exigence d'un retour rapide à
l'ordre constitutionnel c'est la
condition posée par la cedeao réunis en
sommet à accra au ghana la
correspondance de serge daniel mes chefs
d'état qui se sont réunis ici en
constater que qui avait les a priori
favorable vis-à-vis du nouvel homme fort
du burkina faso il de mission ont été
dépêchés sur place une mission steve
hill et les missions militaires qui sont
revenus ici pour parler aux chefs d'état
en disant nous pouvons tenter de leur
faire confiance donc ce qui fait qu'ils
ont échappé à d'autres sanctions mais
attention de demandes importantes ont
été faites à ici à accra aps libération
immédiate du président à roques bac
kaboré l'ancien président qui a été
arrêtée depuis le coup d'état et qui est
ensuite en ville dense humeur et puis
ensuite il a été demandé à la junte de
ouagadougou d'organiser deux sorties de
proposer un calendrier pour aller
rapidement aux élections évidemment ici
on a parlé également du mal il va lui en
a parlé du mali et de la guinée sur le
mali les sanctions ne sont pas levés
parce que justement les chefs des temps
estimait que la jeune malienne les
autorités maliennes n'ont pas présenté
un nouveau calendrier pour aller aux
élections il avait proposé les autorités
maliennes avaient proposé cinq ans n'e a
répondu la cedeao
l'alerté rouge maintenu cette nuit
encore dans une partie de l'océan indien
le cyclone vaz hirai s'éloigne de l'île
de la réunion mais de très fortes pluies
et des rafales de vent sont encore
douter d'autant plus que la tempête se
dirige maintenant vers la côte est de
madagascar dont soir avoue gaël aventure
vous êtes la correspondante de france 24
à tananarive merci d'être avec nous
qu'elle la région de mahanoro est
particulièrement exposée aux risques
comment est-ce qu'on se prépare à faire
face à l'arrivée de cette tempête
vous savez c'est très compliqué de se
préparer à une catastrophe naturelle
d'une telle ampleur dans un pays comme
madagascar un pays pauvre où les gens
toute l'année sont déjà sur le fil ou en
temps normal on manque cruellement de
moyens je me rappelle que ce cyclone
selon les prévisionnistes sera intense
puissants dangereux d'une violence
inouïe qui sera ce sera un cyclone
équivalent à un ouragan catégorie 4
c'est-à-dire avec des dégâts
irréparables donc c'est un peu la double
peine finalement pour madagascar parce
que il y à peine deux semaines de cela
est bien la grande île a été frappée par
la tempête anaky a provoqué de graves
inondations dans la capitale est
aujourd'hui à l'heure où je vous parle
il ya encore des milliers de personnes
qui ont les pieds dans l'eau qui n'ont
plus de logement qui sont obligés d'être
hébergés dans des centres et qui
aujourd'hui survivent grâce à
l'assistance de l'état et une assistance
qui arrivent au compte gouttes qui est
encore insuffisante donc on est encore
dans une situation très précaire
la capitale ne s'est pas encore
totalement relever de la tempête anna et
pour cette tempête cette tempête hanau
parle de 55 mille sinistrés sur toute
l'île pour le cyclone bâti rails on
s'attend à six cent mille sinistrés
surtout madagascar donc le gouvernement
a déjà décrété l'état de sinistres
national 17 régions sur 23 sont en
alerte jaune et seront ce vendredi en
alerte rouge les équipes de secours
notamment l'armée sont déjà mobilisés
dans les zones qui seront les plus
impactés par ce cyclone avec des
vedettes rapides des zodiac à
disposition pour les évacuations
nautique et le gouvernement a également
pris des mesures pour cesser toute
activité et donc les écoles de tout le
territoire seront fermées et les
activités également des entreprises sont
à l'arrêt juste au moins jusqu'au moins
au départ du cyclone des premières
dispositions donc été prise tout de même
merci beaucoup gaël merci pour toutes
ces précisions
deux jours après l'attaqué dont il a été
la cible président mba lo appellent la
population à reprendre le cours d'une
vie normale ce sont ses mots déclaration
faite depuis le palais du gouvernement à
bissau au sugar de rapprocher le chef de
l'état est retourné sur les lieux de
l'assaut il attribue la tentative de
coup de force de mardi un groupe de
bandits je vous propose de l'écouter
cet acte a été commis par un groupe de
bandits qui voulait prendre le pouvoir
sous les ordres d'un autre groupe comme
eux
écoutez je suis ici avec tous les chefs
militaires y compris le chef
d'état-major par intérim
ce qui vient de se passer est vraiment
triste cet acte fera à nouveau parler de
la guinée-bissau dans le monde entier
et je ne pense pas que cela nous rend
digne
depuis plus de 48 heures une course
contre la montre est engagée dans le
village de à bab el oued près de
chefchaouen dans le nord du maroc un
petit garçon de 5 ans ryan c'est son nom
est accidentellement tombé dans un puits
asséché il a pu recevoir de l'eau et de
l'oxygène et le secours restent
mobilisés pour tenter de le faire
remonter à la surface mais le pluie et
étroits et difficiles d'accès seule
solution pour sauver cet enfant creuser
tout autour du site et puis sachez que
le hashtag de sauver ryan a très vite
été relayée sur les réseaux sociaux
en tunisie la consultation nationale se
poursuit des questions auxquelles les
citoyens répondent en ligne 50 mille
personnes au moins se sont déjà
connectés sur la plateforme leurs
réponses doivent en principe servir de
base aux réformes constitutionnelles et
législatives prévues pour cet été
reportage de diablesse et hamdi kelly
dans ce quartier populaire de tunis sidi
hassine la consultation nationale se
fait à plusieurs les employés est ce
qu'ils ne savent pas lire ou qui n'ont
pas accès à internet chez eux
les questions portent sur le type de
régime politique l'économie ou encore la
culture des thématiques très large avec
des choix de réponses parfois
difficilement accessible à tous les
questions sur les thématiques
économiques et politiques ne sont pas
vraiment compréhensible pour le plus
grand nombre seules les questions de
société sont vulgarisés
en tunisie 7 45 % des foyers ont accès à
internet dans ce café les avis restent
mitigés sur l'utilité de cette
consultation
la consultation ne va rien changer c'est
seulement s'il ya des progrès concrets
que je reconnaîtrais ses effets d'autres
comme ce chômeur se sont quand même
connecté par curiosité certaines
questions sont éco problèmes du
quotidien quelles sont les solutions
pour limiter le chômage dans les régions
cette question évoque un problème majeur
personnellement j'en souffre regardez je
suis au café en milieu de journée
pourquoi parce que ça fait longtemps que
je suis au chômage
mais difficile de savoir comment les
réponses vont être interprétés et par
qui depuis son lancement la plateforme
suicide beaucoup de critiques à cause du
manque de communication et de
transparence autour du projet à haute
elle a exprimé sa crainte que l'argent
public soit exploité dans l'élaboration
d'une consultation fictive au service
d'un projet personnel du président de la
république et surtout que ça pose
vraiment plusieurs de plusieurs
problèmes par rapport à la fiabilité
selon les ong n'y a pas non plus
d'informations sur la composition du
comité en charge de collecter les
données une consultation qui doit
s'achever le 20 mars prochain
l'opposition dénonce une manoeuvre
politique
la côte d'ivoire maintenant et cette
promesse du président ouattara il
s'engage à faire de la lutte contre la
corruption sa priorité pour l'année à
venir en tous les cas pour l'exemple
depuis l'automne dernier des policiers
présumés corrompus comparaissent devant
des tribunaux militaires veillent ce
reportage de samuel bernard
le coeur de la lutte contre la
corruption c'est ici au tribunal
militaire d'abidjan des policiers ou
gendarmes accusés de corruption ou de
raquettes comparaissent parce que toutes
les semaines depuis septembre les
autorités ont décidé d'accélérer la
cadence le président du tribunal ange
kessy est devenu malgré lui le visage de
cette nouvelle bataille que tente de
relever le gouvernement sur la
commission existe
depuis bien longtemps depuis 1960 reste
néanmois s'arrête pour voir quel est
l'état de la société je pense que ouvert
estimé qu'il est temps que nous
puissions passer à la vitesse
supérieure dans la lutte contre la
corruption en 2010 9 59% des ivoiriens
estimait que le gouvernement réponde est
mal ou très mal à la corruption dans
l'administration publique parmi les
fonctionnaires considérés comme les plus
corrompus les policiers et gendarmes
figure est en première place face au
phénomène du ministre de la bonne
gouvernance souhaite élargir davantage
le spectre ne s'agit pas uniquement
comme certains pensent pouvoir dire rien
que de petits poissons je vais dire
toute la chaîne de la corruption au sein
des forces de défense et sécurité sont
visés par
la question de la détection de la
corruption de nombreuses arrestations y
compris de personnalités de la haute
administration ont eu lieu ces derniers
mois une avancée que salue cet
humanitaire spécialiste des questions de
corruption il plaide cependant pour plus
de transparence le problème c'est qu'on
ne sait pas quelle est la base un qui a
suscité la poursuite est ce que c'est un
rapport qui a été reçu par le ministère
ou bien ce sont des saisines et qu'il y
a eu et c'est important pourquoi parce
que ça permet à l'opinion publique de
savoir que ce ne serait pas vraiment une
une intention du gouvernement par
exemple de nuit à des personnes en
fonction de l'appartenance politique le
président de la république alassane
ouattara a promis d'inscrire la lutte
contre la corruption au rang des
priorités du gouvernement en 2022 notre
invité ce soir c'est rémy eden bonsoir
merci avec nous vous êtes auteur
compositeur interprète
et pianiste un artiste presque accomplie
alors vous affolé la toile en ce moment
un rémy avec ce titre le goût de vous va
regarder écouter un extrait on se
reparle juste après
[Musique]
sa saveur
la première question que je me suis
posée en écoutant le morceau delà du
fait d'avoir envie de danser très le
goût de quoi le goût de 2 c'est vrai
qu'on reste quand même si sur leur faim
voilà donc on pourrait se dire c'est une
chanson d'abord qui parle d'espoir mais
qui parle aussi d'évolution en fait dans
la vie voilà parce qu'on quitte une
étape à pour arriver à une étape et donc
le goût de la réussite de goût de
l'évolution le goût du bonheur le goût
de succès le goût de france deux cas du
conte la france 24 voilà donc toute une
panoplie de choses qu'on peut conclure
envoyée et vous parlez de succès à
l'instant plus de 30 millions de vues
sur tik tok plus de 12 millions de vues
sur youtube c'est une très belle
performance dépenses et à qui il
s'adresse ce morceau en particulier
qu'est votre public le public en fait le
public je dirais c'est d'abord ma team
bin voilà c'est comme ça j'ai sinon tout
est parti d'une part ce qu'on dit bin
voiture la team been qui maquille qui me
soutient beaucoup mais aussi tous les
amoureux de de couper décaler tous les
amoureux de musique africaine mais c'est
vrai que dans la musique de rémy donne
en outre on y trouvera du r'n'b l'afro
donc cette poussée dans ce style là que
vous direz vous vous inscrivez vous
aujourd'hui ouais je dirais que je
ferais là je fais de la diam's musique
parce que c'est comme ça que je qualifie
ma musique voilà parce que je dis c'est
une musique qui vient du ciel en fête
voilà donc ce que d'immenses que vous
dites voilà c'est dit ça devient donc on
essaie de faire de belles choses qui
touchent beaucoup de personnes mais un
jeune rat je vise un public plus large
en fait je sais pas seulement les jeunes
je pouvais faire danser les grands
reptiles des pontons les tentes et tout
voir et ça marche et sont ma foi ce
moment
c'est ce qui plaît ouais jusqu à savoir
puisque à lhassa avant se plaint pas
donc on continue d'envoyer de belles
choses vous n'étiez pas spécifiquement
particulièrement disposés à une carrière
musicale je crois parce qu'en les un
petit peu votre bio vous étiez vous
étiez en train de poursuivre des études
notamment au niveau de licence à
l'université
houphouët boigny qu'est ce qui a fait
vous avez poussé la première fois dans
les portes d'un studio est en 2017 je
crois effectivement en 2002 mais sièges
2016 2017 ou sur l'entrée en studio pour
la première fois à la suite de ça il ya
le hasard
bon comme dit ''très vont lui asa
n'existe pas mais on dira en dit ravi on
dira si le coup parce que je partais de
passe accompagné notamment qui chantait
déjà quitté rappeur jay-z n'a donc pas
tel accompagné en studio donc c est
comme ça qu arriver là bas c'est lui qui
devait chanter sera distinct featuring
voilà qui perd la voix sur le coup et
c'est comme ça que je pose en fait et on
me dira tout le monde appréciera mais
c'est bon c'est bon ensuite ça a à voir
naître le groupe un défi parce que j'ai
déjà évolué en groupe en groupe d'érable
ont été trois et voilà mon pour répondre
à votre question je dirai simplement que
le virus de leur musique lorsqu'ils te
pique ben on finit par s'attacher c'est
comme des enfants tu vois on finit tous
par s'en passer et puis ensuite tout est
allé très vite 2018 votre premier single
pas comme eux 2019 juste pour moi
monmousseau tout est allé très vite ce
que vous avez pas que ça s'arrête je
vous le souhaite absolument pas mais
quand ça va très vite qu'est ce qu'on
fait pour que ça dure alors que ça
s'arrête j'irai pas parce que je suis
quand même préparé à ça voilà j'ai
vraiment beaucoup bossé pour être à ce
niveau aujourd'hui on le voit dans
l'accord et notamment à tu vois même
beaucoup mieux beaucoup évolué et je
sais beaucoup bossé pour ça j'ai pas
plus que ça s'arrête parce que je me dis
que c'est un set a été un beau début moi
je me suis retrouvé à la musique je
pense que c'est c'est pas pour s'arrêter
là donc je crève pas ça c'est quand je
vais aller très loin on va faire de
grandes scènes on va remporter et vous
reviendrez nous leur a confié son avocat
nazis sont des européennes ensuite je
voudrais aussi si vous le voulez bien
vous nous chantiers ici même à capella
votre tout dernier morceau c'est un peu
dans son lit mais ouais là bas avec
plaisir pour des à nouveau dossier on
s'en va là bas y ils ont cassé bave de
réussite on s'en va là bas oui c'est à
nouveau convoi deux doigts ou on s'en va
là bas ma chérie onction du mariage est
versée on s'en va là bas et à on n'a
qu'à chanter helge lund et on s'en va là
va y est on s'en va là bas et on s'en va
la voir comme ça au port du pirée où il
est né on s'en va france car ils sont à
la bonne heure vers les étoiles ce titre
c'est un clin d'oeil je crois un artiste
ivoirien aussi mais oui pourquoi ce ce
clin d'oeil pourquoi cet hommage cet
hommage vous avez pour moi mais aux
essais j toujours ces légendes vivantes
en fait c'est une grâce pour la côte
d'ivoire qui est mon pays parce que il a
il a fait beaucoup là on a voyagé moi
j'ai été bercé au son de sa musique on a
agrandi il a son style de musique sur
son style d'objet qu'est le zoblazo
voilà qui s'est lui selon radio qui
maîtrisa peut y mettre un peu son sujet
donc j'ai toujours voulu en fait lui
rendre hommage dans ma musique mais le
comment ça devrait suffire je savais pas
et bien avec cette chanson j'ai beaucoup
senti j'ai pas bougé pas beau c'est sûr
j'ai bossé avec mon arrangeur en cire
avec un magnifique compositeur aussi aux
pays où les bénédictions et voilà avec
l'apport aussi de meiway il a réagi
voile alors il arrive ce qui faisait la
gare ils étaient ils et elles étaient
plutôt contents contents de cet hommage
qui était en fait réservé et voilà il
m'arriva il a apporté beaucoup aussi et
aventure chien tu manges et guillaumin
ouais le projet commun si vous regardent
peut-être passer le message que si tu
nous regardes voici ton fils tu sais
voilà donc je sais que une chasse à
vassieux merci beaucoup
a quitté le sud est notre invité ce soir
et merci à vous de votre attention
restez avec nous sur france24
d'information continue je